wie genau hat joe biden ist eigentlich
geschafft diese wahlkarte die am abend
der wahl noch tiefrot schien und immer
noch in großen teilen rot ist zu seinen
gunsten zu drehen und ich werde ihnen
das versuchen noch einmal an einer
vermutlich letzten zeichnung dann haben
sie auch genug von meinen zeichnungen
deutlich zu machen
ich habe einmal die versucht die
vereinigten staaten von amerika so in
groben umrissen für sie nachzuzeichnen
und die frage ist in den letzten monaten
ist das thema oft gewesen babbels wir
leben alle inzwischen in unseren babbels
gehören vor allem nur noch das was
unsere freunde sagen wir hören nur noch
die eigene meinung und so ungefähr ist
auch der amerikanische wahlkampf
gelaufen es ist viel auf social media
passieren die menschen haben in ihren
babbels kommuniziert und nur noch das
gehört was das eigene lager kommuniziert
hat und der donald trump immer wieder
gerne fragt wer hat das größte wer die
größten fragen wir uns jetzt mal wer hat
die größten babbels das sind die
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
überall in den vereinigten staaten von
amerika überall überall gibt es trump
babbels hier tomba bild start von
bubbles im süden im osten überall hier
unten in florida gibt es troubles alles
voller troubles das ist das der grund
dafür dass donald trump ungefähr 70
millionen stimmen geholt hat doch mal
deutlich mehr ungefähr 67 millionen
stimmen als noch vor fehlern er hat das
ganze land mit kleinen trump babbels
gefüllt in denen er erfolgreich ist und
gewählt worden ist kleinen tramp a benz
überall in diesem gebiet aber besonders
hier in diesen gebieten gibt es große
große große große besonders hier oben im
nordosten der usa besonders hier aber
auch im rest des landes so bleiben
babbels in den job beiden waren es das
sind meistens die städte das sind die
urbanen diesen job beiden babbels haben
überdurchschnittlich viele menschen joe
biden gewählt zumal vor allem in den
städten dort wo die minority sind dort
wo die tendenziell eher liberal
demokratische ausgerichteten
wählerschaften sind und vor allem da
die briefwähler schafften sind haben
menschen die beiden gewählt und am ende
ist dieses ergebnis zustande gekommen
weil donald trump zwar die fläche
beherrscht in der fläche überall seine
kleinen tramp a benz hat aber wie wir es
hier eben wir schauen jetzt noch einmal
wenn sie sich die bubbles merken hier
auf das modell pennsylvania pennsylvania
schauen wir uns auch einmal an wenn der
schirm ist uns ausmacht machte schirm
und pennsylvania auf das schule macht
und sich pennsylvania auch wenn der
schirm und pennsylvania aufgemacht hätte
dann hätten sie dort sehen können
überall in pennsylvania alles voller
babbels bis auf die vier großen städte
die sind voller großer joe biden bubbles
und das ist genau das programm in den
letzten in den letzten monaten versucht
hat zu mobilisieren hier in der fläche
aber hier in den großstädten wo die
vielen vielen menschen wohnen dort ist
es zur beiden gelungen seine wähler zu
mobilisieren und vor allem hat er es
geschafft sie schon vor der wahl zur
briefwahl zu mobilisieren das heißt
schon bevor diese wahllos gegen hannover
hatte joe biden sehr sehr viele stimmen
die man auf der wahlkarte des abends
aber nicht gesehen hat weil diese
stimmen besonders hier in pennsylvania
wo die wahl entschieden wurde
erst da wurde er diese briefwahlstimmen
erst nach den am wahltag abgegebenen
stimmen ausgezählt damit war
pennsylvania erst dunkel dunkelrot dass
er alles gut aus für donald trump dann
kann die briefwahl stimmen dazu und dann
wurde immer deutlicher dass diese großen
babbels am ende stand semenya dominiert
werden und das führt am ende zu den 270
stimmen die die beiden braucht oder über
270 elektra awards um ins weiße haus
einzuziehen die wie nele das hat er
jetzt geschafft und damit haben wir
glaube ich genug erst mal erklärt
darüber wie die stimmen in den
vereinigten staaten so verteilt sind wie
dieses land sich ja tatsächlich bei
dieser wahl gespalten hat dem was wir
tatsächlich sehen
joe biden hat über 70 millionen stimmen
geholt donald trump aber auch knapp über
70 millionen das heißt da stehen sich
jetzt zweimal 70 millionen menschen
gegenüber die vollkommen unterschiedlich
leben wie ein leben in ihren kleinen
babbels man kann sich das tatsächlich
bildlich so vorstellen in kleinen
ortschaften auf kleinen farmen auf dem
flachen land und die anderen leben in
ihrem großen babbels babbels wie new
york babbels wie los angeles babbels wie
pittsburgh und philadelphia in
pennsylvania wo
das rennen gewonnen wurde und auch dort
hat man relativ wenig verständnis für
die menschen in den kleinen bargeld
sowie die menschen in kleinen babbels
relativ wenig verständnis für die
menschen in den großen babbels haben und
das ist das was jetzt vor joe biden
liegt das ist das amerika das aufgeteilt
in babbels aufgeteilte amerika was jetzt
vor joe biden liegt und was er in den
kommenden vier jahren zu einem hat mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren